hello everyone and welcome to a game
that pretty much ended before it even
began now we are in the semi-finals of
defeated grand prix currently being
played in belgrade as you know this is
the second leg of the phoenix grand prix
first one finished by alevan arunan and
hikaru nakamura being the top two
contenders now we are looking for the
top two contenders of the second grand
prix and then there will be the third
one and whoever does best two people
will qualify for the next candidates
tournament we know the first six and we
uh need two more so this is the first
game of the semi-finals rehab rapport
versus maxim bashar al-agrav it's uh
well
something that we've seen many times but
it keeps repeating and it's just well
one of the reasons why i also
not just left the quote above the board
but it's something that we discussed in
the previous video so i will be
interested to hearing what you guys
think about that as well uh so let's see
what happened and why this uh well ended
before it even began so rapport with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c for g6 knight to c3 and
of course d5 maximum goes for his
groomfield defense and you pretty much
know this if you play d4 you know that
maxine goes for the groomfield and if
you play e4 you know that maxine goes
for the knight of sicilian so it's very
easy for players to prepare for maxime
on the other hand you will get positions
that maxim most likely knows a lot
better than you so
it's definitely playing on his territory
unless you really really surprise him
very well
which is kind of maybe what happened in
this game so here i see captures on d5
we go into the main line e4 challenges
the knight knight captures b captures on
c3 and bishop to g7 so it's pretty much
a theme of this opening that it will be
a battle for the d4 square
bishop to c4 and now c5 again black
strikes against the d4 square we have
knights to e2 defending the d4 square
and now black castles the safety we have
bishop to e3 again adding another
defender to the d4 square and knight the
c6 really putting a lot of pressure on
that d4 square as we mentioned uh and
here the the the absolute most popular
move is just castles but here we have
rook to c1 uh it's the second most
popular so still nothing out of the
ordinary this is something maxine knows
uh in his sleep we have c captures on d4
uh we have c captures and now queen to
a5 with check we always mentioned that
it definitely makes sense to move the
rook away from the a1 square if the
position opens up you do not want it
stranded there so queen a5 delivering
check
and asking white what do you do here so
you can defend against this check in a
variety of ways you can play king to f1
which is the most popular move here it
uh
well you will not be able to castle but
it has been found that it's really not
necessary to castle here the other way
is to block with queen to d2 you could
also play bishop to d2 but that's a
little bit weird because you need this
bishop to guard the d4 pawn
or you could play what was played in
this game and that is rook to c3 an
incredibly rare move it's been played
only on a few occasions but uh still
probably something that maksim knows
very well uh he strikes against the d4
square again we have e5 attacking d4 and
now we advance at pawn to d5 and now how
do you how do you play here one way is
to just move the knight but the other
way and the seemingly more correct one
is to play b5 and this is something that
maksim uh doesn't seem to have amongst
the well
his uh
army of lines uh and the idea is after
b5 changing the bishop here of course
white will move the bishop and now you
go knight b4 you go after the light
square bishop white will castle you will
capture on d3 and once the queen
recaptures you will now play b4 and look
at this your b pawn travel all this way
it comes to b4 with tempo attacks the
rook once the rook moves this bishop is
coming to a6 and there are a lot of
white pieces on this light square
diagonal so this is the way to play this
however now after maxim's move which is
very very tricky
uh it's not going to be
as simple because there are some games
in the database where queen to d2 was
played you're just allowing the rook to
move uh so not not trying to blend or
anything but here rapport goes back
bishop to d2 and it is now as of move 14
that we have a completely new game so
you are threatening already some nasty
discoveries with the rook uh but if you
look at the position there really aren't
uh all that many yeah if any uh because
well where will you move the rook what
will you attack there's nothing to
attack really so here just bishop to d7
maxim says i'm not afraid of any
discoveries here because well there just
aren't any but here comes knight
captures on the four e captures on d4
and now rook back to the starting square
not the starting starting square but the
second starting square so rook to c1
opens up a discovery against the queen
and now queen to a3 keeping an active
queen and you are very happy with black
because you already have a past the
d-pawn white also has a past deep on but
yours is well uh could be tricky to grab
hold of this one but not upper just
place queen to b3 he offers a queen
trade and why not you have the black
pieces you go for an early queen trade
you draw the game
and well you win the next one with the
white pieces definitely makes sense so
here are queen captures on b3 bishop
captures on b3 and now rook ate the e8
again that makes very much sense the e4
pawn is attacked you can't really do all
that much with the king and e1 and if
you defend it of course we will strike
against the center with f5 but the
question is should we do this uh because
rapport defends with f3 and now it's a
question what do you play here
well best for black is not the move
maxine played most definitely it's to
just play something like rook to c8 but
still it's uh it's a white whose
position is better uh but here after f5
uh it just all falls apart for maxine
and this is only move 19. so feel free
to pause the video and try to find why
it all falls apart for black while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
very difficult line to spot and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course uh
rook to c7 that's the good stuff we are
attacking the bishop here and there's
really not all that much you can do here
now you could move the bishop or you
could defend the bishop but defending
the bishop isn't really realistic
because if you try and do something like
this bishop g5 that controls a lot of
squares if you play rook to f7 then we
just open up a discover you lose this
rook so you are losing something
whatever you play and another thing if
you let's say play bishop to c8 again
just a d6 check king to h8 and d7 again
you will lose something so here uh he
goes for the only square possible and
that is bishop to b5 but now comes the
move that you had to find in order to
play rook to c7 and that of course is
pawn to a4 this is what robert played
and now there really isn't all that much
for this bishop to do once the bishop
leaves this diagonal
d6 d7 is coming and then with uh
combining all of this with with this
immense control of all the squares uh
there just will be uh it will not be
enough squares for the uh for the black
rook so here we have bishop to d3 now
comes d6 check opens up a discovery king
the h8 now d7 attacks the rook and okay
if rook to d8 we already said that
bishop to g5 is is is enough so here we
have rook to b8 but still now comes
bishop to b4 attacks this rook and now
once the rook defense we can easily go
bishop to e7 so here uh of course maxim
doesn't even try that he plays bishop to
e5 goes for a counter attack uh and now
the simplest way to end this is bishop
captures an f8 bishop captures on c7 and
now bishop to e7 this is a beautiful
move because it gets the bishop out of
harm's way and also if black isn't
careful let's say try something like
bishop b5 you go after the pawn here
bishop f6 is checkmate that's right
that's the power of the bishop pair
right there so after bishop to e7 maxim
has to waste the move to prevent
checkmate king to g7 is played and now
you see the real weakness of f5 now it
just advances the pawn to e5 and now
this pawn is coming to e6 and rapport
will have two the two uh defended pass
pawns on the seventh and the sixth rank
so here we have b5 maxime looking for
some counter play he wants to open up
the position maybe get something like
this in but
it's all very very
unrealistic so bishop to f6 check king
to f8 and now e6 with e7 coming black
cannot allow this so bishop to d8
blocking this uh pawn push and now
bishop to e5 attacking the rook and
going for bishop to d6 check if this
check lands uh it's all over so we have
to guard the d6 square rook the b6
guards this square and now just bishop
captures on d4 again not going for the
rook our real target is the c5 square
and grabbing hold of this diagonal
so here we have rook to c6 we can't play
anything else we have to stop bishop to
c5 check and now we have a captures on
b5 this is one way to victory and it's a
it's a very sure one but we're just
going to show that it's not even
necessary to do this you could also play
a move like bishop to d5 just force
black to
relinquish his control over this
diagonal
and even if black doesn't want to go
bishop to c1 check let's say black goes
back rook to c7 now we force black
because now we've taken away the c6
square from the rook and now once black
does this you you give up the rook and
now you go for bishop to d6 check and
that's the game king g7 e7 uh not much
to do here bishop to a5 check you can
capture here rook d rook d1 check we're
going to play king e3 rook captures on
d5 and finally we promote our pawn to a
queen captures captures we bring another
queen into the game and of course black
is uh well just lost here down too much
material so it's not even necessary to
capture this pawn but uh it's uh you
know and and it it it's it's all right
so
it only prolongs the game a little bit
more so here we have bishop chapters on
b5 and now king f2 now there's no reason
to allow uh such a such a move we have
king to e7 and now we have bishop to e3
again we're saying you are not welcome
here bishop to g5 will end the game
uh so bishop to b6 uh still keeping an
eye on this square while uh or hoping
the trade of the bishop but now rook to
d1 now the if you capture the bishop
this square will be undefended uh but
there's really nothing better bishop
captures an e3 with chuck king captures
and now uh rook to c3 with check we have
king to f4 and he was in this position
animal 37 that maxim bashar al-agrav
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here because after you
defend with rook to d3 yes you have to
keep an eye on that queening square uh
well just rook captures on the three
bishop captures and now the king is well
free to gobble up all of these spawns
there's nothing black can do here
there's no way to attack any of the
white pawns
so it would only be a matter of time
before white
just gobbles up all of them you can give
a nice discovery here but it doesn't
matter king h6 the pawns are now falling
it's a game over so
an incredibly impressive game by rapport
who manages to yet again
surprise uh maxine vashiela we've seen
maxim play some very impressive
groomfield games but uh
from time to time he gets really really
uh surprised like he did here with this
um he probably knows the line and he
knows that knight to d4 was already
attempted but bishop to d2
just gives black a terrible terrible
position to play and especially after
this f5 move it was just completely
unplayable the position was still very
very bad here for black but probably
with absolutely best play not lost but
after f5 it just completely crumbles and
you don't expect something like this
because look at the white king the white
king is in the center of the board you
have rooks on e8 and f8 and you also
have the bishop pair so it's not like
you have nice white has the very
impressive bishop pair you also have the
very impressive bishop player and still
there is nothing you can do after f5 is
played so really really an impressive
showing by rapport and uh it really
shows you uh well okay it would be silly
to say that uh as we've discussed
yesterday uh during the capablanca video
that you have to you know really
prioritize the end game in the middle
game and then only after you reach a
certain threshold you should study the
openings of course both rapport and
maxim
have reached these thresholds and they
are
absolute experts in all parts of the
game but here you can see just how how
easily uh one little mistake in the
opening uh
means especially nowadays
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it maxim most definitely didn't
but he will get one more game to try and
bounce back and force tie breaks or it
will be upward to the finals of this
second leg of the feeder grand prix uh
so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
green from
boom uh zoolong closedblocks.com lucas
telcaris and jonathan lay for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
semi-finals uh until the end uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day